Hello, my name is Anya,
and tonight I will be reading
The Witcher: Blood of Elves.
In this part of the story,
Dandelion, who you know
as Jaskier, is getting tortured.
Let's begin.
"Well?" Rience
made a sign to the reeking man.
"Where is the witcher hiding?
“What is the place called?"
The poet remained silent.
The rope tightened, twisting his hands
painfully and his feet left the ground.
Dandelion let out a howl,
brief and broken
because Rience’s wizardly ring
immediately gagged him.
"Higher, higher."
Rience rested his hands on his hips.
"You know, Dandelion,
I could use magic to sound out
your mind, but it’s exhausting.
Besides, I like seeing people’s eyes
pop out of their sockets from pain.
And you’re going to tell me anyway."
Dandelion knew he would.
The rope secured to
his ankles grew taut,
the bucket of lime
scraped along the ground.
"Sir," said the first ruffian suddenly,
covering the lantern with his cloak
and peering through the
gap in the pigsty door,
"Someone’s coming.
A lass, I think."
"You know what to do,"
Rience hissed.
"Put the lantern out."
The reeking man released the rope
and Dandelion tumbled
inertly to the ground,
falling in such a way that he could see
the man with the lantern standing
at the door and the reeking man,
a long knife in his hand,
lying in wait on the other side.
Light broke in from the bawdy-house
through gaps in the planks,
and the poet heard
the singing and hubbub.
The door to the pigsty creaked open
revealing a short figure
wrapped in a cloak and
wearing a round, tightly fitting cap.
After a moment’s hesitation,
the woman crossed the threshold.
The reeking man threw himself at her,
slashing forcefully with his knife,
and tumbled to his knees
as the knife met with no resistance,
passing through the figure’s throat
as though through a cloud of smoke.
Because the figure really
was a cloud of smoke
one which was already
starting to disperse.
But before it completely vanished
another figure burst into the pigsty,
indistinct, dark
and nimble as a weasel.
Dandelion saw it
throw a cloak at the lantern man,
jump over the reeking one,
saw something glisten in its hand,
and heard the reeking
man wheeze and choke savagely.
The lantern man disentangled himself
from the cloak,
jumped, took a swing with his knife.
A fiery lightning bolt shot from
the dark figure with a hiss,
slapped over the tough’s
face and chest with a crack
and spread over him like flaming oil.
The ruffian screamed piercingly
and the grim reek of burning meat
filled the pigsty.
Then Rience attacked.
The spell he cast
illuminated the darkness
with a bluish flame
in which Dandelion
saw a slender woman
wearing man’s clothes
gesticulating strangely
with both hands.
He only glimpsed her for a second
before the blue glow disappeared
with a bang and a blinding flash.
Rience fell back with a roar of fury
and collapsed
onto the wooden pigsty walls,
breaking them with a crash.
The woman dressed in
man’s clothing leapt after him,
a stiletto flashing in her hand.
The pigsty filled with brightness again
- this time golden -
beaming from a bright oval
which suddenly appeared in the air.
Dandelion saw Rience
spring up from the dusty floor,
leap into the oval
and immediately disappear.
The oval dimmed, but
before it went out entirely, the woman
ran up to it shouting
incomprehensively,
stretching out her hand.
Something crackled and rustled
and the dying oval boiled over,
roaring with flames for a moment.
A muffled sound
as if coming from a great distance
reached Dandelion’s ears, a sound
very much like a scream of pain.
The oval went out completely and
darkness engulfed the pigsty again.
The poet felt the power which
gagged him disappear.
“Help!” he howled.
“Help!”
“Stop yelling, Dandelion,”
said the woman, kneeling next to him
and slicing through the knots
with Rience’s stiletto.
“Yennefer is that you?”
“Surely you’re not going to
say you don’t remember how I look.
And I’m sure my voice is not
unfamiliar to your musical ear.”
“Can you get up?”
“They didn’t break
any bones, did they?”
Dandelion stood with difficulty,
groaned and stretched
his aching shoulders.
“What’s with them?”
He indicated
the bodies lying on the ground.
“We’ll check.”
The enchantress
snicked the stiletto shut.
“One of them should still be alive.
I’ve a few questions for him.”
“This one,” the troubadour stood
over the reeking man,
“probably still lives.”
“I doubt it,”
said Yennefer indifferently.
“I severed his windpipe
and carotid artery.
There might still be
a little murmur in him
but not for long.”
Dandelion shuddered.
“You slashed his throat?”
“If, out of inborn caution,
I hadn’t sent an illusion in first,
I would be the one lying there now.”
“Let’s look at the other one…
“Bloody hell... such a sturdy fellow
and he still couldn’t take it.
Pity, pity—”
“He’s dead, too?”
“He coudn’t take the shock
Hmm… I fried him a little
too hard… See,
even his teeth are charred.
What’s the matter
with you, Dandelion?
Are you going to be sick?”
“I am,”
the poet replied indistinctly,
bending over and leaning his
forehead on the pigsty wall.
Poor Jaskier.
I think we will leave it there,
but thank you for joining me
and I bid you all a good night.